do people still uh
mine cryptocurrency and make money yeah
really it's just the the issue is that
with every consensus mechanism consensus
algorithm
form of consensus essentially how a
blockchain works right you have proof of
work you have proof of stake you have
dedicated proof of stake you have all
these kind of you know you have a dag
directed acyclic graph technology like
hedera hashgraph and and constellation
network
um and so there's a bunch of different
like algorithms and ways to do it
bitcoin mining and ethereum mining for
most people is not going to be an
endeavor that's worthwhile
because bitcoin specifically you need a
lot of money yeah you got to buy those
uh those crazy specialized what the [ __ ]
are they called the ant miners
from from bitmain out of china and
unless you have like a handshake
agreement where you can get a bunch of
miners it's going to be difficult you're
going to be waiting months to year if
you don't get scammed if you do if you
don't get scammed i mean
it's very tough to secure these
legitimately and you need
i assume another handshake agreement
with a local government because i don't
know you know what the rate of power is
at this place but
you know unless you got some cheap
energy you're not gonna make much you're
really yeah it's [ __ ] ridiculous i'd
like dip my toe into it a little bit and
i bought like six of the uh 30 90s and
it makes me like
20 a day so that's ethereum you're
mining ethereum right yeah yeah
you know this is my biggest gripe is
that ethereum 2.0 is not here ethereum
is switching from proof of work right
right to free mistake right and then the
theory mine's gonna be dead and gpu
mining is gonna be worthless
until i find another coin to mine right
which will be a while i mean you can
actually mine a couple different things
you can go into nodes
yeah i know it's a node nodes are my new
favorite thing man i make like a few
hundred bucks a day just by running
notes what the hell is a node
uh it's basically you're you're you're
sometimes you're purchasing a note on a
network right or you're
normally with nodes you're not like
staking so like with staking you get
your coin back right but with purchasing
a node you're actually purchasing it so
like
uh strong block for instance
i don't know
listen all right what do we do what
about uh thor we'll do thor network sure
like thor network uh thor finance
there's dubious for anybody who's new to
this nodes are very dubious there are
some that are good some that are
questionable you need a good strategy
and you need to get exit plan but
essentially you're helping like the
network whatever protocol that is like
approve approved transactions right um
you're validating transactions on a
network and there are bitcoin nodes too
but you're not getting paid if you're
not you know it's not a piece of
hardware no you can actually run it
right on your computer and some of them
are
this is this is my rule of thumb with
them the easier they are to set up
the more risky they are
like that is that
that's with anything right right the
easier
like hex
some of it does i have heard a hex that
guy's been trying to get on this podcast
richard yes so richard hart
is a very interesting and i know this he
hasn't been trying to get on here
somebody's been trying to
set it up to get him on here
richard hart
and they're gonna see they're gonna i
know i'm gonna get tagged on twitter in
my opinion is running what i would
consider to be a
a project with questionable fundamentals
we'll just say that um
hex is essentially
a clone of ethereum you have to you have
to stake your hex for a long time it's
they're also running something called
pulse chain you have to sacrifice to get
on the pulse chain i don't really mess
with it sacrifice what
i'm pretty sure baby you sacrifice your
hands
to get pulse
i'm not i'm not a hex expert i've only
been on the website a few times i've you
know looked at their community i've been
through their stuff i've looked at what
they're doing
um on their website
if you want to scroll down and look at
the very bottom there's a piece of text
abusive text a piece of text oh it's a
it's a small little paragraph it's
essentially like
saying uh you know this is a political
statement you're you're behind freedom
of speech
you know this is not investment also you
know you have to do this if you're about
free speech and and this and that i'm
like what is this man
you know the network is really nothing
new in my opinion it's like
and people will i know they're going to
come with me in my opinion hex is just
like the new big connect in mind who's
going to come at you
they have a very dedicated crypto
twitter
i have yeah they have gone through all
my videos and made hate clips
i'm actually in a music video i'm in a
music video
they call they call us
yeah and there's a hex rap video where
it's like you know they actually have a
few of my buddies and they have them
they have them in caskets
they have their picture and a casket and
it's like they're burying the furus it's
like weird it's a weird why because you
guys talked about that yeah because like
if you're not with us you're against us
i have nothing against hex investors i
just don't think the network is good
it doesn't do much i think it's just
like
there's a reason it's not on coin market
cap you know like where they say it
should there's a lot of networks that do
the same thing
i think it's so hilarious there's so
much competition in all these crypto
networks and crypto coins and people who
are invested in certain ones it's like
it's like such a like a tribal
competitive world in crypto especially
when [ __ ] you combine it with social
media it's just like pouring gas on fire
you can do anything you want you can
fork like you can fork uni swap right
this is what um what's his name ty lopez
is doing he has the radio shack oh my
god i forgot about that guy he has the
radio shack brand and essentially i
looked into this a little bit he's like
forking uni swap and then calling it
radio shack or something like that
like a radio shack decentralized
exchange he bought radio shack he has
the rights to it so he's actually got
the rights to a bunch of like old
companies that no one gives a [ __ ] about
and um he's trying to like modernize the
brand nostalgic
i mean i don't know anyone who's gonna
use that maybe like that's what garyvee
always talks about garyvee's big crypto
guy too
he's more of an nft guy gary vee's a
visionary in a lot of ways um i think he
really you know if anyone if there's
anyone to credit with like
showing that nfts are not just monkey
pictures it's garyvee i gotta give him
props man yeah
yeah yeah he's uh
very knowledgeable about this stuff
pretty much everything i know i learned
from watching his videos
nice yeah so tai lopez is big into this
stuff huh is he selling nfts too i
couldn't give a shot i don't know i just
saw that someone making fun of it the
the problem like i said with crypto is
it attracts the grifters because it's
easy to grift you know and and i've i've
had very public beef with people
um on youtube and other places um
with just you know i'm not going to
elaborate on that but let's just say
we're not we should elaborate on crypto
beef
they're just people that i disagree
i disagree with that i think that are
leading the space in a direction that i
don't agree with and so we have our we
have our moments you know he's no bs
crypto if i think it's bs i'm going to
tell him
we can pull him up on the tv and shame
him right yeah
call him out richard hart where you at
[ __ ] it's not rich for heart no richard
you know
he he's he's
he's not actually
there's worse people in richard hart
yeah he looks very entertaining he's
very like charismatic he's got a really
cool background on his videos
he has a way of like you know he's like
they've got the uh charles manson vibe
yeah i dig that where's he live maybe i
should get him on here
that would be an interesting episode i
would love to see you guys do you know
where he lives oh god no but i'm sure he
would do it he he has a thing where he
like you know has people on his he wants
to go on people's shows to debate he's a
very good debater but he doesn't do it
in person though everything he does is
remote well because it's a security risk
he is quite you know he has a lot of you
know value in crypto and there's a lot
of people who just you know don't like
him so i don't blame him
you know
you know people people in crypto are
kind of weird like that
you